hagamos otro problema donde nos piden
graficar una función en base a las
propiedades de la primera derivada y la
segunda derivada y lo que es interesante
sobre este problema creo yo es que no
nos dan la función tan solo algunos
puntos claves sobre ella que nos dan nos
dan
efe de 03 efe de 0 es igual a 3
también nos dan que efe de 3 es igual a
cero
efe de 3
es igual a cero también nos dan
efe de 6
4 efe de 64
lo que me gusta este problema es que no
puede ser una calculadora no conoce la
función aunque te diera una calculada
gráfica sería inútil en fin vamos a
escribir toda la información para poder
graficar la función también nos dan
vamos a poner ahora toda la información
sobre las derivadas entonces también nos
dan qué
efe prima
tx la primera derivada es menor a 0
el intervalo abierto 03 al ser un
intervalo abierto nos incluye ni el 0 y
el 3
también tenemos que la primera derivada
de f prima de x es mayor a 0 en el
intervalo abierto 36 de esto podemos
deducir que como la derivada del menor a
0 con se aproxima a 3 y es mayor a 0
cuando se aleja de 3 entonces la
derivada tiene que ser exactamente cero
cuando x igual a 3 como no se estipula
de otra manera suponemos que las
funciones continua diferenciable sobre
todo el intervalo ok es la información
que nos dan sobre la primera derivada
que es lo que nos dan sobre la segunda
derivada nos dan que la segunda derivada
la segunda derivada es mayor a 0 la
deriva es mayor a 0 en el intervalo
abierto 0,5 intervalo abierto 0,5 es
decir las funciones cóncava hacia arriba
en el intervalo también nos dan
que la segunda derivada
es menor a 0 es decir las funciones
cóncava hacia abajo en el intervalo
abierto 56 y no nos da más información
acerca de lo que pasa después de 6
quizás hay un punto inflexión no sabemos
entonces vamos a suponer que las cosas
no cambian
después de x 6 entonces qué es lo que
nos dice esta información vamos a
graficar la f de 0 igual a 3 tenemos que
graficar los puntos 0,33 0 y 6-4
por lo visto toda la acción ocurre en el
primer cuadrante captare eso en la
gráfica así que me voy a enfocar en el
primer cuadrante este es mi eje x
y aquí tengo mi eje y
geográfica 64 así es que aquí tenemos el
veamos sitio gráfica del punto 64
necesitamos
1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 aquí tenemos el
punto 6 4 el punto 6 4
ok ahora 30 vamos a criticar el punto 30
aquí lo tenemos este es el punto
punto 30 o tu información de aquí es
donde obtuve información y quiero el
punto 0 3
veamos 123 aquí tenemos el punto 0,3
estos son los puntos que nos dan esta
información que nos dan de mí tienen son
puntos que están en la función que más
nos dan nos dicen que f prima de x es
menor que cero en 0,3 es decir que de
aquí acá la función decrece 0.3 a 30 la
función decrece la derivada es menor que
cero de 0 a 3 a 30 la función decrece
entonces lo que nos dicen es que la
función no hace algo así la función no
hace a algo así y como sabemos esto pues
si la función fuera hacia arriba y luego
hacia abajo tendríamos aquí una derivada
positiva y eso no es posible porque aquí
nos dicen que es negativa en todo el
intervalo es decir la función decrece en
todo el intervalo así que la pendiente
es negativa en todo el intervalo
y luego nos dicen que f prima de x es
mayor que 0 el intervalo 36 es decir la
función tiene que crecer en el intervalo
36 puede hacer algo así o algo así pero
no puede hacer curva hacia abajo porque
si era curva hacia abajo la pendiente
sería negativa en algún punto
esencialmente lo que tenemos es que la
gráfica es monótona de este punto este
punto y de este punto este punto
si queremos verlo técnicamente el
teorema de monotonía nos garantiza que
la derivada tiene que ser cero en este
punto o bien es un punto donde la
derivada no existe pero esto es
suponiendo que la función es
diferenciable en todo este intervalo de
hecho ni siquiera necesitamos un teorema
sabemos que la pendiente es negativa
cuando nos aproximamos en este intervalo
y la pendiente es positiva en este otro
intervalo y suponemos que leiva es
continua lo cual no han especificado
pero a falta de esa información lo
podemos hacer si la tasa de incremento o
decremento de esta función es continua
entonces tiene que ser forzosamente cero
en este punto de acuerdo pues es menor a
cero aquí y mayor que cero aquí así es
que voy a dibujar una pequeña línea
horizontal aquí indicando que la
derivada tiene que ser cero tiene que
ser un punto mínimo yo creo ahora veamos
la información sobre la segunda derivada
veamos que nos dan nos dan que la
segunda diva da es mayor que cero de
cero a cinco
de 0 a 5 aquí tenemos 5 de 0 a 5
esencialmente que nos dice que las
funciones cóncava hacia arriba de 0 a 5
eso nos da bastante información pues nos
dice que no sólo la función decrece
monótonamente a medida que nos
aproximamos a 3 y lo hace con una
concavidad hacia arriba y porque cóncava
hacia arriba bueno veamos aquí la
pendiente es negativa luego se hace
menos negativa menos negativa aquí se
hace 0 y luego empieza a hacerse
positiva es decir continúa
incrementándose así hasta llegar a 5 y
entonces de 5 a 6 que pasa la segunda
derivada es negativa es decir de 5 a 6
la concavidad es hacia abajo así que de
5 a 6 las funciones cóncava hacia abajo
déjame agarrar un color adecuado para
dibujar esto no sé cuál es el valor de
la función pero lo que sí sabemos es que
las funciones cóncava hacia abajo así
que f de 5 no sabemos cuál es el valor
de f de 5 no nos los dan
pero si sabemos que tenemos un punto de
inflexión ene efe de 5 hay la función
cambia de cóncava hacia arriba con cava
hacia abajo y creo que es todo lo que
podemos hacer con esta gráfica no puedo
saber más puntos precisos por donde pasa
de hecho hicimos un par de suposiciones
acerca de la diferencia habilidad y la
continuidad de la función en fin creo
que esto te da cierta intuición acerca
de lo que pasa con primeras segundas
derivadas y ese tipo de cosas y para que
lo sepas para este punto de inflexión
nos pueden haber dicho que mi prima
evaluada en 5 es igual a 0 no lo sabemos
a ciencia cierta pero lo estamos
suponiendo en fin espero que hayas
encontrado esto más o menos más o menos
útil de hecho dado que tengo tiempo
déjame darte un bonus haciendo un
problema extra fue escrito justo después
de ese problema así que por qué no
hacerlo y dice así prueba que una
función cuadrática no tiene puntos de
inflexión como se ve una función
cuadrática una función cuadrática se ve
así
fx es igual aa x cuadrada más bx más c
así que nos piden probar que esta
función no tiene puntos de inflexión y
que es un punto de inflexión aquel donde
la segunda derivada
0 calculemos entonces la segunda
derivada empecemos con la primera
derivada la primera deriva una
cuadrática de esta cuadrática y
cualquier cuadrática puede escribirse
así es igual a 2 x + b cuál es la
segunda derivada bien la segunda
derivada es igual a 2a
un punto de inflexión es cuando la
segunda derivada es igual a cero y la
pregunta que tengo para ti es puede esta
función ser igual a cero bien la única
posibilidad de que esto sea cero es si a
es igual a cero pero si es igual a cero
estamos en la ecuación cuadrática sería
tan solo la opción b x + c que es una
línea recta así que para una ecuación
cuadrática donde a tiene que ser
distinto de cero si no no sería una
ecuación cuadrática no hay manera que
esta expresión 2a sea sea igual a cero
entonces hemos probado que la segunda
derivada nunca es igual a cero y por lo
tanto una función cuadrática no tiene
puntos de inflexión nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo